This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. A few short years ago, if you needed to buy something, you would take a walk down to a corner shop or go to a mall. If you wanted to watch a movie, you went to a theater. On nights you didn't want to cook, you stepped out to a restaurant. Shopping, entertainment and dining brought us into contact with other people. Waiting in line at checkout or standing in a crowded bar, we encountered a wide spectrum of humanity. Nice people, mean people, boring people. Today, many of us choose convenience and comfort over connection.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。就在短短几年前，如果你需要买东西，你会步行去街角的商店或去商场。如果你想看电影，你会去电影院。在不想做饭的晚上，你会去餐馆。购物、娱乐和餐饮让我们与他人产生接触。在结账排队时或站在拥挤的酒吧里，我们接触到了形形色色的人。好人、刻薄的人、无聊的人。今天，我们许多人选择了便利和舒适，而非人际连接。
Need something from the grocery store? Plug your order into your phone. Want to see a movie? Fire up Netflix on your computer. Need to check in on friends? Hop on Instagram. You can pay someone to walk your dog or stand in line for you at a concert. Dating apps allow you to check out potential mates
需要从杂货店买东西吗？在手机上输入订单即可。想看电影吗？在电脑上打开Netflix。需要关心朋友吗？刷刷Instagram。你可以花钱请人遛狗，或者请人替你在音乐会排队。约会软件让你可以在
from the safety of your couch. Why go out when you can order in? Some time ago, the food delivery app Seamless launched an ad campaign plastering signs all over the New York City subway. In bright colors with big yellow font, the ads read, over eight million people in New York City, and we help you avoid them all.
沙发上安全地挑选潜在伴侣。既然可以点外卖，何必出门呢？前段时间，外卖应用Seamless发起了一场广告活动，在纽约市地铁的各个角落贴满了标语。广告用鲜艳的颜色和醒目的大号黄色字体写道：纽约市有超过八百万人，而我们帮你避开他们所有人。
How do we get here? When did the world become a place where friendship meant liking a photo? This week on Hidden Brain, the source of the powerful vortex that warps the way we feel about the world, and how to fight its gravitational pull. We are all born with eyes filled with wonder. We play, we laugh, we seek out friends.
我们是怎么走到这一步的？世界是从什么时候开始变成了一个友谊意味着给照片点赞的地方？本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们将探讨那股扭曲我们对世界感受的强大漩涡的源头，以及如何对抗它的引力。我们每个人出生时都怀着充满惊奇的双眼。我们玩耍，我们欢笑，我们寻找朋友。
with eyes filled with wonder. We play, we laugh, we seek out friends. But at some point, this changes. We erect defenses against the world. We pull back from strangers. We retreat into ourselves. What was that moment for you? Was it when you got bullied in middle school? When a friend betrayed your trust?
怀着充满惊奇的双眼。我们玩耍，我们欢笑，我们寻找朋友。但在某个时刻，这一切改变了。我们筑起防线抵御世界。我们疏远陌生人。我们退缩到自己的内心世界。对你来说，那个时刻是什么？是你在中学被欺负的时候吗？还是当一个朋友背叛了你的信任的时候？
When the grind of living paycheck to paycheck became too much? At Stanford University, psychologist Jamil Zaki is interested in how our experiences shape our view of the world and how our view of the world shapes what we experience. Jamil Zaki, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's a pleasure to be here. Thank you. Jamil, some time ago you came across a story about a young Japanese artist. He said he had discovered something about himself on a New Year's Eve. Who was this young man and what was his story? His name is Atsushi Watanabe. He's an artist living in Japan and he, through a long series of events,
当靠薪水度日的生活压力变得难以承受的时候？在斯坦福大学，心理学家贾米尔·扎基对我们的经历如何塑造我们对世界的看法，以及我们对世界的看法如何塑造我们的经历很感兴趣。贾米尔·扎基，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里。谢谢。贾米尔，前段时间你偶然发现了一个关于一位年轻日本艺术家的故事。他说他在除夕夜发现了关于自己的一些事情。这个年轻人是谁，他的故事是什么？他的名字叫渡边笃。他是一位居住在日本的艺术家，通过一系列漫长的事件，
had become quite isolated and in fact was isolated entirely in his room for many months. He had begun his period of isolation during a day in July, which in Japan is known as Sea Day, or Umi no Hi. And on New Year's Eve, he was on a streaming site, and he saw somebody else on that site comment, the last time I saw the sky was sea day, meaning that this person had been isolated and inside for nearly six months. And Watanabe realized with horror that that was true of him as well. Atsushi Watanabe grew up about 25 miles outside of Tokyo in a city called Yokohama. His life was chaotic. He fought with his sister, and according to Atsushi, his father did not get along with
他变得相当孤立，事实上，他在自己的房间里完全与世隔绝了许多个月。他开始这段隔离期是在七月的一天，在日本被称为“海之日”。而在除夕夜，他正在一个流媒体网站上，看到网站上有人评论说：“我最后一次看到天空是在海之日”，这意味着这个人已经与世隔绝、足不出户近六个月了。渡边惊恐地意识到，他自己也是如此。渡边笃在距离东京约25英里的横滨市长大。他的生活很混乱。他和姐姐打架，据阿笃说，他的父亲与
the people around him, and his mother didn't do much to alleviate the situation. So he felt very embittered and disappointed towards them. He was very talented from a young age at art and crafts, and sort of escaped into art and Found that that became a career for him He went to a specialized high school and then to Tokyo University of the Arts and and really it created beautiful Works throughout his childhood and early adulthood. I Mean that sounds wonderful. I mean he was pursuing a career as an artist. It sounds wonderful, I agree. For him it was more complicated than that. Watanabe really wanted his art to help people. He wanted to use it as social
周围的人相处不好，而他的母亲也没有采取什么措施来缓解这种情况。所以他对他们感到非常痛苦和失望。他从小就很有艺术和手工艺天赋，某种程度上逃避到了艺术中，并发现这成为了他的职业。他上了一所专业高中，然后进入了东京艺术大学，在童年和成年早期创作了非常美丽的作品。我的意思是，这听起来很棒。我的意思是，他正在追求艺术家的职业生涯。这听起来很棒，我同意。对他来说，情况比这更复杂。渡边真的希望他的艺术能帮助人们。他想把它作为社会
commentary and he thought that others in the art world would likewise be driven by these values of connection and altruism. Instead, he found that art, like any other career, is full of careerists, people who are often quite competitive and compare themselves to each other. Watanabe, like so many of us, suffered from depression and anxiety, and being put in this pressure cooker of an industry just made it worse and worse
评论，他认为艺术界的其他人也会同样受到这些连接和利他主义价值观的驱动。相反，他发现艺术和其他任何职业一样，充满了职业主义者，这些人往往非常具有竞争性，并且互相攀比。渡边和我们许多人一样，患有抑郁症和焦虑症，而置身于这个行业的压力锅中只会让情况变得越来越糟，
and eventually became unbearable for him. At one point after seeing so many of his peers posting about their awards, he ended up breaking his phone and retreating to his parents' home, a place that he wanted to use as an escape, but which really wasn't that comforting for him because his relationship with his parents was still so strained. So at what point did he withdraw to his room and become essentially a recluse?
最终变得让他无法忍受。有一次，在看到许多同龄人发布他们的获奖消息后，他最终摔碎了手机，退回到了父母家，一个他想作为避难所的地方，但对他来说并没有那么舒适，因为他与父母的关系仍然非常紧张。那么，他是在什么时候退缩到自己的房间，本质上变成了一个隐士的呢？
I believe it was in 2010 and he again started feeling more and more alienated, first from the art world and then more and more from even his family. I think of his life, and this is from an outsider's perspective, as shrinking, like the circumference of a circle, becoming smaller and smaller, until the only place that he felt safe and comfortable was in this tiny few square feet of his room. He had joined what could be thought of as a community really having an experience known as hikikomori, a Japanese term for total social isolation.
我相信是在2010年，他再次开始感到越来越疏远，首先是与艺术界，然后是与家人的疏远也越来越严重。从局外人的角度来看，我觉得他的生活在萎缩，就像圆的周长一样，变得越来越小，直到他感到安全和舒适的唯一地方就是他房间里那几平方英尺的地方。他加入了可以被认为是一个社区的东西，实际上经历了一种被称为“蛰居族”（hikikomori）的状态，这是一个日本术语，指完全的社会隔离。
It's almost like being in a jail cell, except it's a cell of your own creation as opposed to something imposed on you by the state. How does the story unfold, Jamil? What happens next? Well, he stayed in isolation for months after that. And again, from an outsider's perspective, it seems like the circumference of your mind shrinks as well.
这几乎就像是在监狱牢房里，只不过这是一个你自己创造的牢房，而不是国家强加给你的。故事是如何展开的，贾米尔？接下来发生了什么？嗯，在那之后他又在隔离中待了几个月。同样，从局外人的角度来看，似乎你的思想周长也在萎缩。
Watanabe began to fear that maybe he and the world would never reconnect again, that maybe he would live the rest of his life in that one room. At some point, his family decided to launch something of an intervention. Tell me what happened. Yeah, his father, who he had never gotten along with, decided he had had enough. And he contracted with a service in Japan that specializes in involuntarily pulling recluses out of their homes. And Watanabe, upon learning about this from his mother, was infuriated.
渡边开始担心，也许他和世界永远不会再重新连接了，也许他余生都会在那一个房间里度过。在某个时刻，他的家人决定发起某种干预。告诉我发生了什么。是的，他一直合不来的父亲决定受够了。他联系了日本一家专门强行将隐士从家中带出的服务机构。而渡边从母亲那里得知此事后，愤怒不已。
He broke down his door and set out to confront his family, but there was no one there. They were out for the day. What he did find surprised him. He found in the living room a lot of books that he had never seen, and paging through them, he realized that his mother had bought all these books about social isolation in an attempt to understand and support her son. And that moment of realizing that in her own way she was trying her best to be there for him really broke down his defenses. She came home and they sat and talked for hours, opening up about the pain that they had been through and how they might move forward.
他撞开门，准备去和家人对质，但那里没有人。他们那天出去了。他发现的东西让他感到惊讶。他在客厅里发现了很多他从未见过的书，翻阅这些书时，他意识到他的母亲买了很多关于社会隔离的书，试图理解并支持她的儿子。那一刻，意识到她正以自己的方式尽最大努力去陪伴他，这真的打破了他的防线。她回到家，他们坐下来谈了几个小时，敞开心扉谈论他们所经历的痛苦以及他们如何才能继续前进。
He had not spoken in so long that his throat dried up in trying to speak and he had to drink lots of water even to be able to have this conversation. But he said that at that moment, the captivity of his heart went away for good. that moment, the captivity of his heart went away for good. What happened to Atsushi over the ensuing months? How has he turned out since then, Jameel? Atsushi is, to me, an absolute inspiration and a redemption story.
他已经很久没有说话了，以至于他在试图说话时喉咙干涩，他不得不喝大量的水才能进行这次谈话。但他表示，那一刻，他内心的囚禁彻底消失了。那一刻，他内心的囚禁彻底消失了。在接下来的几个月里，阿笃发生了什么？从那以后他怎么样了，贾米尔？对我来说，阿笃是一个绝对的灵感来源，是一个救赎的故事。
He went to a clinic to rehabilitate his body and mind for several months and then he turned his period of isolation into art. In one of his first pieces he built a concrete structure and isolated himself in it for seven days and then at the end of the seven days with a hammer broke himself out of his captivity and what I find so beautiful about this is that he was mimicking the experience of isolation but owning it transmuting it into something that other people could understand and this time instead of opening the door into his
他去了一家诊所，花了几个月时间康复身心，然后他将自己的隔离期转化为了艺术。在他最早的作品之一中，他建造了一个混凝土结构，并将自己隔离在其中七天，然后在七天结束时，用一把锤子把自己从囚禁中敲了出来。我发现这非常美妙的一点是，他是在模仿隔离的经历，但却掌控了它，将其转化为其他人可以理解的东西。这一次，当他逃离囚禁时，打开的不是通往他
living room when he escaped his captivity there were photographers and an audience and his art has inspired so many. He's made lots of pieces like this, bringing awareness to the pain of isolation and has become an extremely successful and in-demand artist in Japan. So about 300 miles from where Atsushi lived in Tokyo is the city of Kobe. You talk about two Japanese neighborhoods in Kobe. They were only a few miles apart, but they were also very different. How so, Jamil? Yeah, so these are two neighborhoods known as Mano and Mikura. On paper, pretty similar, both working class neighborhoods with lots of factories, for
客厅的门，而是面对着摄影师和观众，他的艺术激励了许多人。他创作了许多这样的作品，提高了人们对隔离痛苦的认识，并已成为日本一位极其成功且炙手可热的艺术家。那么，距离阿笃居住的东京约300英里处是神户市。你谈到了神户的两个日本社区。它们相距仅几英里，但却截然不同。怎么说呢，贾米尔？是的，这两个社区被称为真野（Mano）和御藏（Mikura）。在纸面上，它们非常相似，都是有很多工厂的工人阶级社区，例如，
instance, but they had different histories. Mano had a lot of family businesses and a lot of local trade between people who were also neighbors. It also had a history of activism. People in Mano had fought for environmental protection, for instance, together. And that had bonded them in common cause over the decades. So you can think of Mano as a very tight-knit, trusting, and interdependent community. Mikura had less of that history, and people were less connected, less interdependent,
但它们有着不同的历史。真野有很多家族企业，邻居之间也有很多本地贸易。它还有着激进主义的历史。例如，真野的人们曾共同为环境保护而斗争。几十年来，这使他们因共同的事业而紧密联系在一起。所以你可以把真野看作是一个非常紧密、互相信任和相互依赖的社区。御藏则缺乏那种历史，人们之间的联系较少，相互依赖程度较低，
and potentially less trusting of one another as well. So in 1995, a massive earthquake hit Kobe and its surrounding neighborhoods. The tremors sparked fires that lasted for days and destroyed over 100,000 buildings. More than 6,000 people died. What happened to these two neighborhoods, Jamil? Yeah, this was a horrible tragedy, but really, if you think about it and look at
而且彼此之间的信任度可能也较低。所以1995年，一场大地震袭击了神户及其周边社区。震动引发了持续数天的大火，摧毁了超过10万座建筑物。超过6000人死亡。这两个社区发生了什么，贾米尔？是的，这是一场可怕的悲剧，但如果你仔细思考并查看
the historical record, it was more than one tragedy because it was experienced so differently by these different neighborhoods. In Micurah, people watched often in their nightclothes, in their pajamas, while buildings were reduced to ash. In Mano, people did not wait for the authorities. They banded together and fought the fires themselves. For instance, running hoses from factories or creating pop-up bucket brigades to bring water from rivers to fight the fire again on their own. And because of that, the damage was far less in Mano than in Makura. Again, here you see this trusting neighborhood banding together in a way that protected them
历史记录，这不仅仅是一场悲剧，因为这些不同的社区对它的经历截然不同。在御藏，人们常常穿着睡衣，眼睁睁地看着建筑物化为灰烬。在真野，人们没有等待当局。他们团结起来，自己扑灭了大火。例如，从工厂拉出软管，或者建立临时的水桶接力队，从河里取水来灭火，再次依靠他们自己。正因为如此，真野的损失远小于御藏。在这里，你再次看到了这个互相信任的社区团结在一起，以一种保护他们的方式，
and likely saved many lives. You know, Jamil, when we think about cities and neighborhoods, we often think about physical infrastructure. We think about, you know, fire brigades and roads and access to water and electricity. And obviously, those things are important. You're pointing to something far subtler here at the level of human psychology. Absolutely, Shankar. I think that's beautifully put. We have the physical infrastructure that
并可能挽救了许多生命。你知道，贾米尔，当我们想到城市和社区时，我们通常会想到物理基础设施。我们想到的是，你知道，消防队、道路以及水和电的供应。显然，这些事情很重要。你在这里指出了人类心理层面更微妙的东西。绝对是这样，尚卡尔。我觉得你总结得非常好。我们拥有
connects us, but for that to work as well as it can, we also need a psychological infrastructure. We need a sense of interconnection. You know, the same way that we are all wired together through satellites and telephone wires, we must be psychologically wired together. And the networks that do that are networks of faith in one another, a sense of common purpose and shared values. That social infrastructure, that sense of common purpose and interdependence is crucial to continuing and flourishing together. When we come back, how we become disillusioned and distrustful of the world
连接我们的物理基础设施，但要使其发挥最大作用，我们还需要心理基础设施。我们需要一种互联感。你知道，就像我们所有人通过卫星和电话线连接在一起一样，我们必须在心理上连接在一起。而实现这一点的网络是彼此信任的网络，是一种共同的目标感和共同的价值观。那种社会基础设施，那种共同的目标感和相互依赖感，对于我们继续共同繁荣至关重要。当我们回来时，我们将探讨我们是如何变得对世界感到幻灭和不信任的，
and the surprising effects this has on us. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Every morning, you wake up and face the world. What does it look like to you? Do you see a paradise with endless opportunities, where people are friendly and helpful? Or a world filled with injustice, where people cannot be trusted? At Stanford University, psychologist Jamil Zaki is interested in how the way we view the world shapes our experience of it.
以及这给我们带来的惊人影响。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。每天早上，你醒来面对这个世界。它在你眼中是什么样子的？你看到的是一个充满无限机会的天堂，那里的人们友好且乐于助人吗？还是一个充满不公正、人们不可信的世界？在斯坦福大学，心理学家贾米尔·扎基对我们看待世界的方式如何塑造我们对世界的体验很感兴趣。
Jamil, in the examples we've discussed, the way that individuals and groups feel about one another seems to shape how they behave toward one another. You say that across the world, many of us have been stricken by a worldview that sees the world in a harsh and negative light. What is this worldview? This worldview, Shankar, is cynicism. That is, the belief that people in general are greedy, dishonest, and untrustworthy. And it is on the rise.
贾米尔，在我们讨论的例子中，个人和群体对彼此的感受似乎塑造了他们对待彼此的方式。你说在世界各地，我们许多人都被一种以严苛和消极眼光看待世界的世界观所困扰。这种世界观是什么？这种世界观，尚卡尔，就是犬儒主义。也就是说，认为人们普遍是贪婪、不诚实和不可信的。而且它正在抬头。
A survey that came out several years ago found that 12th graders, people who are just entering adulthood, were even less trusting than older generations. I think only 18% of them believed that most people can be trusted. So some time ago we had the psychologist Jerick Lifton on Hidden Brain and he talked about some of his research on parents desire to keep their kids safe by teaching them that the world is a dangerous place. In some ways do you think parents and other caregivers could be partly to blame for their kids becoming mistrustful? I think that parents are probably to blame for a lot about their children both the good and the bad. But certainly I think that is a big factor. So I love Jare's work and
几年前发布的一项调查发现，12年级的学生，也就是刚刚步入成年的人，比老一辈人更不信任他人。我想只有18%的人认为大多数人是可以信任的。所以前段时间我们在《隐藏的大脑》节目中请到了心理学家杰里克·利夫顿，他谈到了他关于父母希望通过教导孩子世界是一个危险的地方来保护孩子安全的一些研究。在某种程度上，你认为父母和其他照顾者是否应该为孩子变得不信任他人承担部分责任？我认为父母可能要为孩子们的很多方面负责，无论是好的还是坏的。但当然，我认为这是一个很大的因素。所以我喜欢杰瑞的工作，
as you describe he interviewed hundreds of parents and asked them what do you think will help your child? What beliefs do you think will help them? And more than half believed that in order to help their child they should make them feel like the world is dangerous instead of safe. And I want to say, I can really understand why a parent would feel that. As a parent, I felt that way too. We think it's our job to protect our children from the slings and arrows of the world. But it turns out that if you teach your children that the world is full of slings and arrows, they'll walk around with a shield all the time, and that might not actually help them.
正如你所描述的，他采访了数百名父母，问他们：你认为什么能帮助你的孩子？你认为什么样的信念能帮助他们？超过一半的人认为，为了帮助孩子，他们应该让他们觉得世界是危险的，而不是安全的。我想说，我真的能理解为什么父母会有这种感觉。作为一名家长，我也曾有过这种感觉。我们认为保护孩子免受世界的伤害是我们的职责。但事实证明，如果你教导孩子世界充满了伤害，他们会一直带着盾牌走来走去，而这实际上可能并不能帮助他们。
So by teaching our kids that the world is dangerous, we might be keeping them safer from certain risks, but we also are exposing them to a huge risk of living a diminished and less fulfilled life. So as you just said, a number of studies show that people with lower trust tend to be less happy, less healthy, less engaged in their communities compared with people who have higher levels of trust. Economists have measured the effect of trust on a nationwide level, and they've compared countries with one another.
所以，通过教导我们的孩子世界是危险的，我们可能让他们免受某些风险，但我们也让他们面临过一种平庸且不充实的生活的巨大风险。正如你刚才所说，许多研究表明，与信任水平较高的人相比，信任度较低的人往往不太快乐、不太健康、在社区中的参与度也较低。经济学家在全国范围内衡量了信任的影响，并将各国进行了比较。
What do they find, Jamil? Yeah, trust at a social level is incredibly important. Of course, if you as a person can trust, that's good for you. If we as people can trust, that's excellent for all of us. As we saw in the story of Kobe, this neighborhood of Mano that was very trusting was agile and able to pivot that community in times of crisis. But trust helps us in good times as well. Trusting nations tend to have people in them who are more willing to
他们发现了什么，贾米尔？是的，社会层面的信任极其重要。当然，如果你个人能够信任他人，这对你有好处。如果我们作为一个群体能够信任他人，这对我们所有人来说都是极好的。正如我们在神户的故事中看到的那样，真野这个非常互相信任的社区在危机时刻表现得灵活且能够迅速调整。但信任在顺境中也有帮助。信任度高的国家往往拥有更愿意
volunteer and donate to charity, who participate in civic life more, for instance voting more. They tend to have greater levels of happiness nationally, and they tend to do better economically. of happiness nationally, and they tend to do better economically. Economists once measured the trust of dozens of nations and then the growth in their GDP over the following years, and they found that high trust nations increased in their economic health over the years, while lower trust nations stagnated or even shrunk economically. One of the statistics that I found really jaw-dropping was that in terms of well-being, living in a high-trust group is worth as much as a 40% pay raise.
志愿服务和捐赠慈善的人，他们更多地参与公民生活，例如更多地参与投票。他们往往拥有更高的国民幸福感，而且在经济上也往往表现得更好。国民幸福感，而且在经济上也往往表现得更好。经济学家曾衡量过几十个国家的信任度，然后衡量了它们随后几年的GDP增长，他们发现高信任度国家在多年间经济健康状况有所提高，而低信任度国家则停滞不前甚至经济萎缩。我发现的一个非常令人震惊的统计数据是，就幸福感而言，生活在一个高信任度的群体中相当于加薪40%。
That's incredible, Jamil. That's right. And again, I think it comes back to this beautiful metaphor you raised earlier of social infrastructure. If you feel as though you are part of a community, evidence shows from so many angles that that is salutary, positive for both your physical and mental health. So cynics turn out to be highly critical of others and themselves, and you say that even though you were running a lab studying empathy, you fell into this trap yourself the first year that you were teaching at Stanford. Can you tell me what happened?
这太不可思议了，贾米尔。没错。而且我认为这又回到了你之前提出的关于社会基础设施的美妙隐喻。如果你觉得你是社区的一部分，从许多角度来看，证据表明这对你的身心健康都是有益的、积极的。所以犬儒主义者最终会对他人和自己都非常挑剔，你说即使你当时在经营一个研究同理心的实验室，你在斯坦福教书的第一年也陷入了这个陷阱。你能告诉我发生了什么吗？
Yeah, this is a story that I'm not very proud of, but I think is important to tell. So I started at Stanford in 2012 and was extremely anxious. You know, this is the job that I dreamed of my entire adult life. And finally it was handed to me. And the pressure that I felt from that was indescribable. I felt completely sure that maybe Stanford had made an error in hiring me and certainly I wasn't going to make it
是的，这是一个我不太引以为豪的故事，但我认为讲出来很重要。我于2012年开始在斯坦福工作，当时非常焦虑。你知道，这是我整个成年生活梦寐以求的工作。终于它落到了我头上。我从中感受到的压力是无法形容的。我完全确定斯坦福可能在聘用我时犯了一个错误，而且我肯定无法
to tenure. The other thing that happens when you start a lab is that you no longer are dependent only on yourself. You're dependent on the people you hire, in my case post-docs and graduate students and staff. I figured that my job was to absolutely in an anxiety-ridden way make sure that everyone was as productive as I needed them to be and as they needed to be to succeed in the exact same way that I had. I think that I
获得终身教职。当你开始经营一个实验室时，另一件事是，你不再仅仅依赖自己。你依赖于你雇佣的人，在我的情况下是博士后、研究生和员工。我想我的工作就是以一种焦虑的方式，确保每个人都像我需要的那样高效，并且像他们需要的那样成功，就像我曾经做的那样。我想我
was probably a very stressful person to have as a leader and actually I don't just think that I know it. About a year into the life of my lab one of the people that I was trying to train urgently requested a meeting. And so we met and she was in tears and said, you know, this work is really stressing me out and it's just unsustainable for me. I feel as though my mental health is taking a hit in this lab and if things don't change I'm going to leave. Frankly Shankar, I feel
可能是一个作为领导者让人感到非常有压力的人，实际上我不仅仅是这么想，我知道是这样。在我实验室成立大约一年后，我试图培养的人员之一紧急要求开会。于是我们见面了，她泪流满面地说，你知道，这项工作真的让我压力很大，对我来说是不可持续的。我觉得我的心理健康在这个实验室受到了打击，如果情况不改变，我就要离开了。坦率地说，尚卡尔，我感到
some shame, almost a visceral response, even talking about it now. Yeah, yeah. But it is, I mean, it is sort of striking, right? Because you're an empathy researcher and you've created something of a toxic environment in your own lab. That is, I mean, the mismatch between that
一些羞耻，甚至是一种发自内心的反应，即使现在谈论它也是如此。是的，是的。但这确实，我的意思是，这有点惊人，对吧？因为你是一位同理心研究员，而你在自己的实验室里创造了一种有毒的环境。也就是说，我的意思是，两者之间的不匹配
must have been very jarring. It was a rich and very painful irony that I felt immediately. And I have to say, I'm extremely grateful to that person for having the bravery to step up and challenge a new boss at that time. And I learned a lot from that moment and changed. But at that time, I realized that my cynicism was really not just getting the better of me, not just stopping me from living the life I wanted,
一定非常令人震惊。这是一种丰富且非常痛苦的讽刺，我立刻就感受到了。我必须说，我非常感谢那个人有勇气站出来挑战当时的新老板。我从那一刻学到了很多，并做出了改变。但在当时，我意识到我的犬儒主义确实不仅在打败我，不仅在阻止我过上我想要的生活，
but it was creating harm to others. And that really was a very hard realization. I should say, Jamil, that I've known you now for a few years, and I think you are one of the kindest and most generous people that I know. So I have no doubt that in some ways you've learned from these experiences and changed. But it is striking that many of the qualities that you describe that cynics have, a tendency to withdraw into themselves or to be distrustful or to be highly critical, these are things striking that many of the qualities that you describe that cynics have a tendency to Redraw into themselves or to be distrustful or to be highly critical. These are things that you found in yourself Absolutely, and I think that there's a lot of reasons for that cynics tend to be people who have been harmed in the past
而且它还在伤害他人。那确实是一个非常艰难的认识。我应该说，贾米尔，我已经认识你几年了，我认为你是我认识的最善良、最慷慨的人之一。所以我毫不怀疑你在某些方面从这些经历中吸取了教训并做出了改变。但令人震惊的是，你描述的犬儒主义者拥有的许多特质，比如退缩到自己内心、不信任他人或非常挑剔，这些都是令人震惊的，你描述的犬儒主义者拥有的许多特质，比如退缩到自己内心、不信任他人或非常挑剔。这些是你自己在自己身上发现的东西。绝对是这样，而且我认为这有很多原因。犬儒主义者往往是过去受到过伤害的人，
and I had a relatively hard family life and I think that that created that sense of defensiveness, that idea that I needed to protect myself in order to survive. And I think that those lessons die hard and for me they've lingered. And I consider myself these days a recovering cynic in that I'm working on these qualities in myself, even as I try to teach others about them. ["Symphony No. 5 in D minor, Op. 11, No. 5 in C major"] So there have been a number of different studies looking at the effects of cynicism in different
而我有一个相对艰难的家庭生活，我认为这造成了那种防御感，那种为了生存而需要保护自己的想法。我认为这些教训很难磨灭，对我来说，它们一直挥之不去。如今我把自己视为一个正在康复的犬儒主义者，因为我正在努力改善自己的这些特质，即使我试图教导他人关于这些特质的知识。["D小调第五交响曲，作品11，C大调第五号"] 所以已经有许多不同的研究探讨了犬儒主义在不同
domains. One of the most striking is in education. In the 1950s, the psychologists Walter Cook and Donald Medley asked teachers whether or not they agreed with three statements. One, no one cares much about what happens to you. Two, most people dislike helping others. And three, most people are honest chiefly through fear of getting caught.
领域的影响。其中最引人注目的是在教育领域。在20世纪50年代，心理学家沃尔特·库克和唐纳德·梅德利询问教师是否同意以下三个陈述。第一，没有人关心你发生了什么。第二，大多数人不喜欢帮助别人。第三，大多数人诚实主要是因为害怕被抓。
And the teachers were asked, do you agree with these statements? Do you disagree with the statements? What did the study find about the effectiveness of these teachers in working with students? Yeah, so Cook and Medley actually gave teachers 50 statements like the three that you just read. But those are great examples. And they were, essence trying to locate individual differences, things that people
老师们被问到，你同意这些陈述吗？你不同意这些陈述吗？这项研究关于这些教师在与学生合作时的有效性发现了什么？是的，库克和梅德利实际上给了老师50个像你刚才读到的那三个一样的陈述。但那些是很好的例子。他们本质上是试图定位个体差异，人们会说的话，他们相信的东西，这些可能会预测他们与学生的关系。确实，也许不出所料，他们发现那些认为人们只会尽可能占便宜，而且你不能对他们太小心的人，并不是好老师，至少在他们与学生的关系方面是这样。但库克和梅德利发现，这并没有止步于课堂。那些积极回答这些问题的人，那些对人性持有这些阴暗看法的人，结果在总体上表现出敌意。他们称之为“犬儒敌意”。如果可以的话，我想用他们的话
would say, things that they believed that might predict their rapport with students. And indeed, maybe unsurprisingly, they found that teachers who thought that people will just get away with whatever they can and you can't be too careful around them weren't great teachers, at least in terms of their relationships to their students, but what Cook and Medley found was that this did not stop in the classroom. The people who answered these questions positively, who believed these bleak things about human nature, turned out to be hostile in general. They called this cynical hostility. And if I might, I'd like to use their words
来自他们1954年写的一篇论文，他们在其中描述了敌对的犬儒主义者是什么样的。他们说，敌对的人是对同胞几乎没有信心的人。他认为人们是不诚实的、反社会的、不道德的、丑陋的和刻薄的，并认为他们应该为自己的罪过而受苦。在聚会上不太受欢迎，这些人可能。所以从那时起，这个犬儒敌意量表已经被用于数百项研究中，结果在一致性方面令人震惊。
from a paper that they wrote in 1954, where they describe what a hostile cynic is like. They said, the hostile person is one who sees little confidence in his fellow man. He sees people as dishonest, unsocial, immoral, ugly, and mean, and believes they should be made to suffer for their sins. Not a hit at parties, these people potentially. So since then, this cynical hostility scale has been used in hundreds of studies, and the outcomes are striking in their consistency.
那些积极回答这些问题的人，那些以这种阴暗和犬儒的眼光看待人性的人，在他们人生的道路上只会受苦并制造痛苦。当你查看数据时，这是一种看待世界的悲剧方式。你能谈谈犬儒主义与抑郁症等心理健康问题之间的恶性循环吗？是的，绝对可以。所以犬儒主义者往往比非犬儒主义者遭受更多的心理健康问题，而且也很难与人建立联系。
People who answer these questions positively, who think of human nature in these bleak and cynical terms, just suffer and create suffering all throughout their path in life. It's a tragic way of viewing the world when you look at the data. Can you talk a moment about the vicious cycle between cynicism and mental health problems like depression? Yeah, absolutely. So cynics tend to suffer many more mental health issues than non-cynics and also have a hard time connecting with people.
与人建立联系是改善我们心理健康的最快方法之一。社会联系就像营养，可以帮助我们从困难时期恢复过来。但对于犬儒主义者来说，情况并非如此。所以这几乎就像是，如果社会联系是药物，它对犬儒主义者不起作用。这几乎就像他们对这种帮助我们其他人的药物产生了抗药性。我想知道有些人此时可能在想，所以犬儒主义有很多负面后果，
Connecting with people is one of the fastest ways to improve our mental health. Social connections are like nourishment that can help us bounce back from difficult times. For cynics though that's not really the case as much. So it's almost as though if social connection is medicine, it doesn't work for cynics. It's almost as though they're resistant to this medication that helps the rest of us. I'm wondering if some people might be thinking at this point, so there are a lot of negative consequences to cynicism,
但怀疑和不信任肯定也有好处。也许它可以让你保持安全。世界上显然有很多暴力、危险和不诚实的人。在发现坏人方面，犬儒主义者比非犬儒主义者更准确吗？这是一个常见的刻板印象，
but surely there are benefits to being suspicious and distrustful as well. Maybe it can keep you safe. There are obviously lots of violent and dangerous and dishonest people in the world. Are cynics more accurate than non-cynics when it comes to spotting the bad guys? This is a common stereotype,
如此普遍，以至于心理学家给它起了一个名字，叫“犬儒天才错觉”，它有两个部分。第一，正如你所说，人们认为犬儒主义是智慧的标志。所以在研究中，如果你向参与者描述一个非常犬儒和一个非常非犬儒的人，并问他们这两个人中哪一个在分析任务上会表现得更好。他们会说犬儒主义者会胜过非犬儒主义者。他们还认为犬儒主义者在社交上很聪明。
so common that psychologists have a name for it, the cynical genius illusion, and it has two parts to it. One, as you're saying, people think that cynicism is a sign of intelligence. So in research, if you describe a very cynical and very non-cynical person to participants and ask them which one of these people would be better at an analytical task. They will say the cynic would outperform a non-cynic. They also think cynics are socially smart.
所以如果你说，嘿，你知道，我想问，我想找个人来检测公司里的人在提交简历时谁在撒谎。85%的人认为犬儒主义者会比非犬儒主义者更擅长测谎。所以大多数人对那些不信任他人的人有信心。这有点绕口，但这是事实。而且大多数人都错了。
So if you say, hey, you know, I want to ask, I want to bring somebody in to detect who's lying in a company when they give their resume. Eighty five percent of people think that a cynic will be a better lie detector than a non-cynic. So most people have faith in people who don't have faith in people. It's a little bit of a tongue twister, but it's true. And most people are wrong.
数据在这里很清楚，犬儒主义者在分析和认知测试中表现较差，而且他们是更糟糕的测谎仪。所以如果你真的让犬儒主义者和非犬儒主义者观察人们进行工作面试，一半的人被告知撒谎，一半被告知说实话，更信任他人的人比犬儒主义者更擅长发现撒谎者。我认为这部分是因为犬儒主义者有一种普遍的、一概而论的理论，即没有人是可以信任的。所以他们实际上，在试图争论时，像检察官一样思考，起诉
The data are pretty clear here that cynics perform less well on analytic and cognitive tests, and they're worse lie detectors. So if you actually have cynics and non-cynics look at people sort of giving job interviews, half of the people told to lie, half told to tell the truth, more trusting people are better at spotting liars than cynics. And I think that's partially because cynics have this general blanket theory that nobody can be trusted. And so they actually, in trying to argue, thinking like lawyers in the prosecution against
人类，停止了真正的倾听，停止了真正的关注证据。所以贾米尔，我想谈谈犬儒主义的一些驱动因素。记者大卫·伯恩斯坦将新闻媒体比作每隔几分钟就会响起的救护车警笛。我觉得你要告诉我，我的职业在滋生犬儒主义方面是问题的一部分。嗯，当然不是你的节目，尚卡尔，但是，但是你知道，我想说我真的认为
humanity, stop actually listening, stop actually paying attention to the evidence. So Jamil, I want to talk about some of the drivers of cynicism. The journalist David Bornstein compares the news media to an ambulance siren that sounds every few minutes. I feel you're going to tell me that my profession is part of the problem when it comes to breeding cynicism. Well, certainly not your show, Shankar, but, but you know, I want to say that I really think that the
新闻业是非常高尚的。伯恩斯坦告诉我的引起了很大共鸣的是，记者们相信，而且我认为真诚地相信，他们能为社会做的最好的事情之一就是指出我们哪里做得不足。揭露和阐明不公正和腐败确实是道德且强大的努力。问题在于，当记者和新闻媒体最终制造了太多的坏消息，以至于他们扭曲了人们对社会现状的看法时。这甚至有一个名字，叫“邪恶世界综合症”。
profession of journalism is extremely noble. What Bornstein told me that resonated so much is that journalists believe and I think sincerely believe that one of the best things they can do to help society is to point out where we're falling short. Exposes and and and shedding light on injustice and corruption are really moral and powerful endeavors. The problem is when journalists and the news media end up producing so much bad news that they skew people's perception of what society is like. This even has a name called Mean World Syndrome.
事实证明，传播科学家发现，一个人看的新闻越多，他们就越认为别人是危险的，越认为犯罪率在上升，越认为自己是不安全的，即使这些事情被证明是不真实的。嗯。我的意思是，我想我们许多人现在都有打开新闻网站的经历，几乎，你知道，每天早上都做好准备，说，你知道，今天我们要被告知什么新的恐怖事件？我觉得每天早上打开手机就像在为电击做准备。你知道，我被电击了太多次，以至于我对
It turns out that communications scientists have found that the more news a person watches, the more they think that others are dangerous, the more they think that crime is rising, the more they think that they're unsafe, even when those things are demonstrably untrue. Hmm. I mean, I think many of us have the experience now of opening a news website and almost, you know, bracing each morning saying, you know, what fresh horror are we going to be told about today? I feel like opening my phone in the morning is like preparing for an electric shock. You know, and I've been shocked so many times that I'm almost desensitized to
它几乎脱敏了，而且常常感到无助。我想我并不是唯一有这种经历的人，但这确实加剧了我的犬儒主义，而且我认为也在加剧我们集体的犬儒主义。你说犬儒主义的另一个驱动因素是我们生活在一个日益交易化的世界中。你这是什么意思，贾米尔？在许多方面，关系有不同的类型。有些关系是我们应该进行交易的，我们应该计算并保持分数，并确保如果我去餐馆，我不仅仅是告诉老板，嘿，那是一顿美味的饭菜，非常感谢。
it and can often feel helpless. And I think I'm not alone in that experience, but it certainly drives up my cynicism and I think is driving up our collective cynicism as well. You say that another driver of cynicism is that we live in an increasingly transactional world. What do you mean by this, Jamil? In many ways, relationships come in different types. There are relationships where we're supposed to transact, we're supposed to count and keep score and make sure that if I go to a restaurant, I'm not just going to tell the owner, hey, that was a delicious meal, thanks so much.
下周我会请你到我家来，对吧？我们应该，我们应该进行交易。我们应该以一种由市场和市场心态定义的方式工作。这是适当的。在其他情况下，我们不应该那样做，对吧？
Next week I'll have you over at my house, right? We're supposed to, we're supposed to transact. We're supposed to work in a way that's defined by markets and market mentality. That's appropriate. There are other cases in which we're not supposed to act that way, right?
如果我的孩子们在父亲节给我做早餐，我说，非常感谢，然后我给他们5美元小费，那也是不合适的，因为我们有一种公共关系，我们应该互相信任，而不是计较分数。我认为让我担心的一件事是市场生活的特征进入公共空间的程度。我认为原因之一是因为我们正在计算更多的东西，就像我们过去
If my kids make me breakfast for Father's Day and I say, thanks so much, and I tip them $5, that would also be inappropriate because we have a communal relationship where we're supposed to trust one another and not keep score. I think that one thing that worries me is the extent to which features of market living are entering into communal spaces. I think that one reason for this is because we are counting more things like we used to
计算金钱一样。我们计算我们在Facebook、Twitter或Instagram等不同平台上获得了多少社会认可。我们计算我们锻炼和冥想了多少。有一些应用程序可以让你和朋友竞争谁走的步数更多。我认为这种量化会让我们觉得我们处于一个交易空间，
count money. We count how much social approval we receive on different platforms like Facebook or Twitter or Instagram. We count how much we exercise and meditate. There are apps where you can compete with your friends for who's taking more steps. And I think that that quantification can make us feel like we're in a transactional space,
即使我们可能并不想这样。所以贾米尔，你说犬儒主义和孤独之间存在一种关系，在某种程度上这可能是一个“先有鸡还是先有蛋”的问题，因为犬儒主义促使人们从世界中退缩，但你是说反之亦然？没错，是的。当你感到退缩时，通常在那种痛苦、孤立和悲伤的空间里，信念和想法就会冒出来。比如，实际上，我只需要关注我自己。
even when we might not want to be. So Jamil, you say that there is a relationship between cynicism and loneliness and in some ways this might be a chicken-and-egg problem because cynicism prompts people to withdraw from the world but you're saying that also the reverse is true? That's right, yes. When you feel withdrawn oftentimes in that space in the pain and isolation and sadness that you feel, beliefs and ideas pop up. Like, actually, I need to focus only on myself.
你在孤独和抑郁中经常看到这种情况，抑郁的人会进行社交退缩，然后他们会开始评判自己或他人，并想，哇，我感到真的很孤独。人们就是不值得信任。也许我不够好。也许他们不够好。我不知道，但无论出于什么原因，
You see this a lot in loneliness and also in depression, where people who are depressed will withdraw socially, then they'll start to judge themselves or others and think, wow, I feel really lonely. People just aren't trustworthy. Maybe I'm not good enough. Maybe they're not good enough. I don't know, but for whatever reason,
我将永远孤独。当人们开始有这些信念时，他们就会开始根据这些信念行事，进一步退缩。犬儒主义可以被认为是一套有毒的自我实现的预言。当我们不相信人们时，我们的行为方式表现出缺乏信心，而他们对此的反应可能会证实我们最初的信念。喜剧演员乔治·卡林曾经说过，刮开一个犬儒主义者，你就会发现一个
I'm going to be alone forever. And when people start to have those beliefs, they then start to act on them withdrawing further. Cynicism is sort of can be thought of as a toxic set of self-fulfilling prophecies. When we don't believe in people, we act in ways that show a lack of faith and they react to that in a way that maybe confirms our initial beliefs. The comedian George Carlin once said, scratch a cynic and you'll find a
失望的理想主义者。人们天生不是犬儒主义者。这是在经历导致他们改变对世界的期望之后发生的。我们许多人已经开始将世界视为一个绝望的地方，人们不可信。我们认为这些观点会保护我们免受伤害，但它们往往最终会产生相反的效果。当我们回来时，如何平衡现实主义与希望？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
disappointed idealist. People are not born cynical. It happens after experience causes them to change their expectations about the world. Many of us have come to see the world as a hopeless place where people cannot be trusted. We think these views will protect us from harm, but they often end up doing the opposite. When we come back, how to balance realism with hope? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们生活在一个容易变得犬儒的世界里。环顾四周，你会发现无数理由相信世界是一个危险、暴力的地方。人们是不可靠、不可信和贪婪的。在斯坦福大学，心理学家贾米尔·扎基研究了这些信念对我们幸福感的影响。在他的书《犬儒主义者的希望：人类善良的惊人科学》中，贾米尔探讨了
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We live in a world where it's easy to be cynical. Look around you and you will find endless reasons to believe the world is a dangerous, violent place. That people are unreliable, undependable, and greedy. At Stanford University, psychologist Jameel Zaki studies the effects of these beliefs on our well-being. In his book, Hope for Cynics, the Surprising Science of Human Goodness, Jameel explores
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是Shankar Vedantam。我们生活在一个容易变得愤世嫉俗的世界里。环顾四周，你会发现无数理由让你相信这个世界是一个危险、暴力的地方。相信人们不可靠、不值得信赖且贪婪。在斯坦福大学，心理学家Jameel Zaki研究了这些信念对我们幸福感的影响。在他的著作《愤世嫉俗者的希望：人类善良的惊人科学》中，Jameel探讨了
the psychology of cynicism and the ways it affects our lives. He says that cynicism doesn't just erode our mental health, it also undermines our ability to fix our toughest problems. Jamil, in 1978, the Czech writer Václav Havel wrote a parable about a grosser living under an authoritarian regime. What was the story? Yeah, this was in Havel's essay,
关于愤世嫉俗的心理学及其对我们生活的影响。他说，愤世嫉俗不仅会侵蚀我们的心理健康，还会削弱我们解决最棘手问题的能力。贾米尔，1978年，捷克作家瓦茨拉夫·哈维尔写过一则关于生活在威权体制下的杂货店老板的寓言。那个故事是什么？是的，这出自哈维尔的散文，
The Power of the Powerless And he wrote about how totalitarian states erode people's trust in one another So in his example this grocer is compelled by his government to hang a slogan in support of a communist regime And he does so he doesn't believe the slogan and his neighbors know he doesn't believe it. So in hanging it up what he's really doing is hanging a white flag of defeat. Other people, his neighbors, hang up their slogans as well and what this does is it sends a sort of message around the entire neighborhood that everyone has capitulated to the regime.
《无权者的权力》。他写道，极权国家是如何侵蚀人们彼此之间的信任的。在他的例子中，这位杂货店老板被迫在店里挂上一条支持共产主义政权的标语。他照做了，但他并不相信这条标语，他的邻居们也知道他不信。所以，当他挂上标语时，他实际上是在挂起一面失败的白旗。其他人，也就是他的邻居们，也挂出了他们的标语，这向整个社区传递了一种信息，即每个人都已经向政权投降了。
And if anybody decides to try to stand up or create social change, the people around them will not have their back. It's a visual cue that people can't trust one another. And of course, what the story suggests is that as we become cynical and mistrustful, it breeds cynicism and mistrust in those around us. That's right. Again, this is a sort of self-fulfilling prophecy in which cynical people tell a story full of villains and then end up living in it. And this is really useful actually for things like totalitarian
如果有人决定站出来或试图推动社会变革，周围的人不会支持他们。这是一种视觉暗示，表明人们无法互相信任。当然，这个故事暗示，当我们变得愤世嫉俗和多疑时，它会在我们周围的人中滋生愤世嫉俗和不信任。没错。这又是一种自我实现的预言，愤世嫉俗的人讲述了一个充满反派的故事，最终却生活在其中。这对于极权主义来说确实非常有用，
regimes. One view of cynicism is often, well, it might not feel good, but it's moral. It's good for us or right for us to pay attention to injustice. And I certainly wouldn't disagree with that. But it's also true that cynics foreclose on the possibility of anything better. And when you lose faith or hope that things could get better, you stop trying. I would say that cynicism is far from a radical worldview.
政权。对愤世嫉俗的一种看法通常是，嗯，它可能感觉不好，但它是道德的。关注不公正对我们有好处或对我们来说是正确的。我当然不会反对这一点。但同样真实的是，愤世嫉俗者排除了任何更好可能性的存在。当你失去对事情会好转的信念或希望时，你就会停止尝试。我想说，愤世嫉俗远非一种激进的世界观。
I'd say it's often a tool of the status quo. So you talk about a concept called hopeful skepticism. What is hopeful skepticism, Jameel? Well, I think it's important to first separate cynicism from skepticism because these two are often confused with one another. As we've been discussing, cynicism is the theory that others are greedy, selfish, and dishonest. Skepticism is really quite different. It's a desire to have evidence to support our beliefs and to not simply accept our assumptions about the world. The idea of hopeful skepticism is twofold.
我想说它通常是现状的工具。所以你谈到了一个叫“希望性怀疑”的概念。什么是希望性怀疑，贾米尔？嗯，我认为首先要把愤世嫉俗和怀疑区分开来，因为这两者经常被混淆。正如我们一直在讨论的，愤世嫉俗是一种认为他人贪婪、自私和不诚实的理论。怀疑则完全不同。它是一种渴望获得证据来支持我们的信念，而不是简单地接受我们对世界的假设。希望性怀疑的理念包含两个方面。
One, it's being open to evidence the way that scientists are, but two, it's understanding that our default is relatively negative and often too negative. We often miss the goodness in others even when it's there. So hopeful skepticism is an openness to the world that is complemented by the idea that, hey, people are probably better than I think, and if I pay attention, pleasant surprises might be everywhere. You say that one of the first steps to becoming a hopeful skeptic is to challenge your own assumptions. You conduct an exercise on yourself that you call reasons to be cheerful. What is this exercise? Yeah, this is one in which I try to notice positive things in my
第一，像科学家那样对证据持开放态度；第二，理解我们的默认心态相对消极，而且往往过于消极。即使善良存在，我们也常常忽略他人的善意。因此，希望性怀疑是一种对世界开放的态度，并辅以这样一种想法：嘿，人们可能比我想象的要好，如果我留心观察，惊喜可能无处不在。你说成为希望性怀疑者的第一步是挑战自己的假设。你对自己进行了一项练习，称之为“值得高兴的理由”。这是什么练习？是的，在这个练习中，我试着去注意我
everyday life and in particular positive things that other people do. I actually started this as a practice with my kids because I realized I was griping to them about all sorts of people and maybe giving them a negative view of the world. So I started trying to notice for them and tell them about everyday positive acts that I had seen. And I noticed that this habit of action, of speech turned into a habit of mind. It was like knowing that I wanted to share
日常生活中的积极事物，特别是其他人所做的积极事情。我实际上是把这作为与孩子们一起进行的练习，因为我意识到我一直在向他们抱怨各种各样的人，可能给了他们一种消极的世界观。所以我开始试着为他们留意，并告诉他们我所看到的日常积极行为。我注意到这种行动和言语的习惯变成了一种思维习惯。就像知道我想分享
positive stories with them popped an antenna out of my head and made me curious and hungry for evidence of positive and kind acts. And once that antenna popped up, it was not hard to find those acts. They are everywhere. It was like changing the lens through which I saw the social world and suddenly alerted me to a world full of generous and open-minded and warm people. You've also studied the impact of small acts of kindness. Tell me about some of this research you've done in your lab. Yeah, so in my lab we study kindness and generosity and empathy. And one of the things that we find is that you often imagine that kindness is a sort of transfer.
积极的故事，这让我的大脑竖起了一根天线，使我对积极和善良行为的证据感到好奇和渴望。一旦那根天线竖起来，找到这些行为就不难了。它们无处不在。这就像改变了我观察社会世界的镜头，突然间，我发现自己置身于一个充满慷慨、思想开放和热情的人的世界中。你也研究过微小善举的影响。跟我说说你在实验室里做的一些研究吧。是的，在我的实验室里，我们研究善良、慷慨和同理心。我们发现的一件事是，你通常会认为善良是一种转移，
I do something for you, you feel better and maybe I pay a cost, maybe I'm more tired or sadder after listening to your hardships or maybe I give you money and I'm broker. It turns out though that everyday acts of kindness are one of the best ways to improve our own wellbeing. But it matters why you do it. I think that many of us can act kindly in a cynical way. You help a friend move because you owe them, or because you feel like you have to. And it turns out that when you act kindly
我为你做点什么，你感觉好些了，也许我付出了代价，也许在听了你的苦难后我变得更累或更难过，或者也许我给了你钱，我变得更穷了。但事实证明，日常的善举是改善我们自身幸福感的最好方法之一。但你为什么这样做很重要。我认为我们许多人可以以一种愤世嫉俗的方式表现得善良。你帮朋友搬家是因为你欠他们人情，或者因为你觉得不得不这样做。事实证明，当你表现得善良时，
from a place of cynicism, that doesn't help you at all. Acting kindly only helps our wellbeing when we do so from a place of compassion and genuine connection. I mean, this goes back in some ways to what you were saying earlier about the tendency we increasingly have to keep score. What you're really saying is that keeping score doesn't help us gain the benefits of generosity and compassion. That's right. That's absolutely right. If you treat life as an exchange, then you can benefit in that setting.
如果出于愤世嫉俗，那对你一点帮助都没有。只有当我们出于同情和真诚的联系而表现得善良时，善良才会对我们的幸福有帮助。我的意思是，这在某种程度上回到了你之前所说的我们越来越倾向于斤斤计较的问题。你真正想说的是，斤斤计较并不能帮助我们获得慷慨和同情带来的好处。没错。绝对正确。如果你把生活当作一种交换，那么你可以在那种环境中获益。
But so much of what matters most in life is what can't be counted. It's the relationships and community that we have just for the sake of it. And when you act even kindly, but from a calculating place, you deprive yourself of that feeling, that feeling of community that I think is so fundamental to who we are as a species and to what allows us to flourish. So I can hear some people saying, you know, Jamil Zaki is telling me to put on rose tinted glasses.
但生活中许多最重要的事情是无法计算的。那是我们为了关系和社区本身而建立的关系和社区。当你表现得善良，但出于一种算计的心态时，你就剥夺了自己那种感觉，那种我认为对我们作为一个物种以及对我们能够繁荣发展至关重要的社区感。所以我能听到一些人说，你知道，贾米尔·扎基在告诉我戴上有色眼镜。
Surely in the face of major problems like war and climate change, it's ridiculous. It's naive to be hopeful. Well, I can hear those people as well because oftentimes they say that to me directly. I don't have to imagine them. And I understand that instinct. Look, in talking about the downsides of cynicism and the upsides of hope, I am in no way wanting
在战争和气候变化等重大问题面前，这肯定是荒谬的。抱有希望是天真的。嗯，我也能听到那些人的声音，因为他们经常直接对我这么说。我不需要想象他们。我理解那种本能。看，在谈论愤世嫉俗的弊端和希望的益处时，我绝不是想
to paper over the real harm and destruction and corruption and pain that saturate our world. Hope is not the same as optimism. Optimism is the belief that things will be better. I think of that as rose-colored glasses and something that can make us even complacent. Hope is the notion that things could get better and it often coincides with a lot of dissatisfaction with how things are now. I think that hope can be a feeling that actually inspires us to challenge these structures, to challenge the forces in our culture that are doing harm.
掩盖充斥在我们世界中的真实伤害、破坏、腐败和痛苦。希望与乐观不同。乐观是相信事情会好转。我认为那是戴着有色眼镜，这甚至可能让我们变得自满。希望是认为事情可能会好转，它往往伴随着对现状的不满。我认为希望可以是一种真正激励我们挑战这些结构，挑战我们文化中造成伤害的力量的情感。
I think of hope as a fiery and often radical emotion, something that is not saying this is fine in a room that's on fire, but rather saying this room is on fire, we can put it out. Jamil says one of his role models when it comes to cultivating a hopeful outlook in life was the late neuroscientist Emile Brunot. They worked on several research projects together. Then in 2018, Emile noticed something odd. In 2018, Emile noticed that each night his laptop screen looked dimmer and dimmer. And then he started getting headaches. He's a neuroscientist, so he knew this was a bad sign. And he asked for a CT scan. And what the doctors discovered was a glioblastoma, which is a very aggressive form of brain cancer.
我认为希望是一种炽热且往往激进的情感，它不是在着火的房间里说“这很好”，而是说“这个房间着火了，我们可以把它扑灭”。贾米尔说，当谈到在生活中培养希望的视角时，他的榜样之一是已故神经科学家埃米尔·布鲁诺。他们曾合作过几个研究项目。然后在2018年，埃米尔注意到了一些奇怪的事情。2018年，埃米尔注意到每天晚上他的笔记本电脑屏幕看起来越来越暗。然后他开始头痛。他是一位神经科学家，所以他知道这是一个坏兆头。他要求做CT扫描。医生发现的是胶质母细胞瘤，这是一种非常具有侵略性的脑癌。
And it's one that would take his life two years later on September 30th 2020. Once Emil found out that he had brain cancer he knew that he didn't have long to live and and the two of you talked on the phone and he told you the news. Can you tell me what happened that day what that conversation was like? I was beside myself with grief and sadness. He had two young children, you know, a loving spouse. He was in his early to mid 40s. It was just this tragedy that his life would be cut short. And in an astonishing turn of events, he started to try to comfort me. Maybe I could have done better there, but he said that although he was of course
这种病在两年后的2020年9月30日夺去了他的生命。埃米尔发现自己患有脑癌后，他知道自己时日无多，你们俩通了电话，他告诉了你这个消息。你能告诉我那天发生了什么，那次谈话是什么样的吗？我当时悲痛欲绝。他有两个年幼的孩子，你知道，还有一位深爱他的配偶。他才40出头。他的生命被缩短，这简直是一场悲剧。在令人震惊的转折中，他开始试图安慰我。也许我当时可以做得更好，但他确实说，虽然他当然
extremely sad and his family was so sad, he also had discovered inside himself this sense of all that is beautiful in the world. He said it lived inside him like a ball of plasma. He told me that none of us get to live forever, but most of us don't know how long we have. And he knew that he had months, maybe a year or two to live, and it just equipped him with this sense of deep determination to live his values to be with his community and to continue
非常难过，他的家人也非常难过，但他也在内心深处发现了世界上所有美好的事物。他说它像一个等离子球一样活在他体内。他告诉我，我们谁都无法永生，但大多数人不知道自己还有多少时间。他知道自己还有几个月，也许一两年的生命，这赋予了他一种深刻的决心，去践行他的价值观，与他的社区在一起，并继续
his work to find the good in people and to promote hope and peace. It was really incredible and it made me think and I still think to this day that there's a difference between a long life and a good life. He knew at that moment that he was going to be deprived of the first. None of us can choose how long our lives are, but he made a choice to have the second, to have a good life. It was one of the most inspirational conversations I've ever had. to have a good life. It was one of the most inspirational conversations I've ever had. So a lot of us Jamil feel like the world hands us things and when those things are good,
他的工作，去发现人们身上的美好，去促进希望与和平。这真的很不可思议，它让我思考，直到今天我仍然认为，长寿和美好生活是有区别的。他在那一刻知道他将被剥夺前者。我们谁都无法选择生命的长度，但他做出了选择，去拥有后者，去过一种美好的生活。这是我进行过的最鼓舞人心的谈话之一。去过一种美好的生活。这是我进行过的最鼓舞人心的谈话之一。所以我们很多人，贾米尔，觉得世界给了我们一些东西，当这些东西是好的时候，
we feel hopeful about the world and when the world hands us bad things, we don't feel hopeful about the world. I think what Emile was saying is that we actually have the agency to choose hope, that hope in fact is an active choice. Oh thank you Shankar that's so well put. That is exactly what I see Emil to have done. His life was by no means easy and he could have chosen to turn his back on the world, to feel as though life had treated him unfairly, and he just refused. His hope was fierce and defiant. And to me, gives exactly the lesson that you're describing, that hope is a choice. It's something that we work on,
我们对世界感到充满希望；当世界给了我们坏东西时，我们对世界就不抱希望了。我认为埃米尔所说的是，我们实际上有选择希望的能动性，事实上，希望是一种主动的选择。哦，谢谢你，尚卡尔，说得太好了。这正是我所看到的埃米尔所做的。他的生活绝非易事，他本可以选择背弃世界，觉得生活对他不公，但他拒绝了。他的希望是炽热而反抗的。对我来说，这给出了你所描述的教训，即希望是一种选择。这是我们努力去做的，
and it's a skill that we can build. I told Emil during that phone call that I was jealous of him. I know that's a strange thing to say to somebody who's just been diagnosed with cancer, but his positivity was just so mind-blowing. And I said, I just don't know anybody who sees the world the way that you do. And he knew that. He said, I know. I know that I have this idiosyncratic view.
也是我们可以培养的一种技能。我在那次通话中告诉埃米尔，我很嫉妒他。我知道对一个刚被诊断出癌症的人说这种话很奇怪，但他的积极态度简直令人难以置信。我说，我不知道还有谁能像你这样看待世界。他知道这一点。他说，我知道。我知道我有这种独特的观点。
I know that I have this intense positivity. And he said, one of the things that I wish is that if I could squeeze that positivity out, like the toothpaste out of a tube, that I could leave it behind, that I could spread it even after I'm gone. And, you know, in the book I try to tell his story and it's my very small way of trying to help him even just a little bit with that mission. Jamil Zaki is a psychologist at Stanford University. He's the author of Hope for Cynics, the surprising science of human goodness.
我知道我有这种强烈的积极性。他说，我希望的一件事是，如果我能把这种积极性挤出来，就像从管子里挤牙膏一样，我能把它留下来，即使在我走后也能传播它。而且，你知道，在书中我试图讲述他的故事，这是我试图在他那个使命上哪怕只帮他一点点的小小方式。贾米尔·扎基是斯坦福大学的心理学家。他是《愤世嫉俗者的希望：人类善良的惊人科学》一书的作者。
Jamil, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. This has been delightful. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty, and please use the subject line, cynical. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes,
贾米尔，非常感谢你今天参加“隐藏的大脑”。谢谢你，尚卡尔。这非常愉快。那个电子邮箱地址再次重申，是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。60秒足够了，请使用主题行“cynical”。“隐藏的大脑”由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、
Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoyed today's story, please do two things. One, tell a friend about our program. Spread the word and the power of these ideas. Second, please consider signing up for a free seven-day trial of our subscription
安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行编辑。如果你喜欢今天的故事，请做两件事。第一，告诉你的朋友我们的节目。传播这些想法及其力量。第二，请考虑注册我们的订阅试用，
feed, Hidden Brain Plus. Building this show is a labor of love, and it makes a big difference to us to know that you have our backs. If you have an Apple device, you can sign up at apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. If you have another device, you can access the subscription via support.hiddenbrain.org.
Hidden Brain Plus，七天免费试用。制作这个节目是一项爱的劳动，知道你们支持我们，这对我们意义重大。如果你有苹果设备，可以在apple.co/hiddenbrain注册。如果你有其他设备，可以通过support.hiddenbrain.org访问订阅。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。